this man wearing gloves a ski mask and  ear protection has slipped onto the  property four times since january walked  into the horse corral and shot horses at  close range but i know we have this  horse situation where there's out there  you know crazy guy shooting horses tell  us a little bit about the story and then  what you guys are doing at peter with  the reward yeah so there's um a guy we  presume he's the same person that's  killed all four of these horses that's  killed horses at short range by gun  in i believe january march june and july  and right now we are offering a five  thousand dollar reward for information  leading to the arrest and conviction of  this person i'm gonna match peta i'll  take that five thousand dollar match and  i'll match peter's five thousand to find  the person who's killing the horses so  derek parent you're a local leader  you're helping people in general so  you're going to match the five thousand  dollars  i'm after 5 000 for peta  [Music]  you